hallo ihr lieben habt ihr auch mal
wieder keine zeit zum kochen und auch
nicht besonders viele zutaten da dann
habe ich jetzt genau das richtige für
euch
ich zeige euch nudeln mit einer leckeren
würzigen ton fischsauce und das gesamte
gericht dauert nur elf minuten
wir benötigen nudeln da könnt ihr die
nehmen die euch am besten gefallen ich
habe hier spiral nudeln genommen
außerdem thunfisch ich habe eine dose im
eigenen saft genommen etwas butter
tomatenmark eine knoblauchzehe sowie
eine zwiebel und dann benötigen wir
creme fraiche oder schmand je nachdem
was ihr da habt und an gewürzen etwas
getrockneten basilikum paprikapulver
salz und pfeffer ich habe das wasser in
einem topf bereits aufkochen lassen und
gäbe da jetzt einen guten schuss salz
mit dazu und las anschließend die nudeln
darin gar kochen
und nun bereiten wir die blitzschnelle
thom fischsauce zu dafür habe ich die
butter bereits in einer beschichteten
pfanne zerlassen und bitte hier nicht
die höchste stufe nehmen damit sie euch
nicht verbrennt und anschließend dünnste
ich darin meine knoblauchzehe und die
zwiebel
dann geben wir das tomatenmark mit dazu
und christen ist auch noch mal ein paar
sekunden mit an damit sich leckere
aromastoffe bilden
jetzt kommt der thunfisch mit dazu und
wird noch mal richtig schön unter
gemengt
hinzu kommt dann noch creme frisch oder
wenn ihr mögt auch gerne schmandt dass
es vollkommen euch überlassen
ich finde beide varianten sehr lecker
und das müssen wir dann auch noch mal
alles gut zusammen
zu guter letzt werden noch unsere
gewürze mit dazugegeben achtet darauf
dass er nicht zu viel salz verwendet
denn der thunfisch ist ja auch schon
salzig genug also daher etwas sparsam
sein und dann würde das ganze um und
dann ist es auch schon fast fertig
die thunfisch soße ist so schon total
lecker ich gebe aber für die konsistenz
immer noch gerne etwas nudelwasser dazu
ich nehme dann ein wenig weg gibt es mit
in die soße und höre dass um und jetzt
ist die soße tatsächlich schon fertig es
hat keine zwei minuten gedauert wir
warten jetzt noch auf die nudeln und
können dann servieren
das rezept habe ich vor einigen wochen
schon auf meiner instagram seite geteilt
und weil das so gut bei euch ankamen und
es zahlreiche nach gemacht wurde dachte
ich mir dann wäre es vielleicht auch was
für mein youtube zuschauer kaum zu
glauben dass dieses gericht nur elf
minuten gedauert hat also falls sie auch
mal keine zeit habt aber trotzdem was
leckeres essen möchtet dann macht es
gerne nach und schreibt mir euer
feedback in die kommentare
ich freue mich sehr wenn wir beim
nächsten mal wieder einschaltet und den
kanal kostenlos abonniert damit ihr auch
keines meiner videos mehr verpasst bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss